foreign
[Music]
talking about getting you a good night's
sleep as you're waking up here on Good
Day Las Vegas Dr Nicole short is joining
us from UNLV and talking about sleep
medicine and importantly the psychology
of making sure you're in the right head
space to get a good night's sleep so
we've talked about sort of what can kind
of get us into the mode where we can't
slip into the frustration that's
associated with it what can people do
what are some crucial things to try and
do to make sure that when you want to go
to sleep you go to sleep yes
especially your wake up time that's sort
of the most crucial signal to your body
to set your body's internal clock so as
much as possible having the same wake-up
time every day even when you are a shift
worker and that may be unpleasant so
trying as much as possible to do that
avoiding naps throughout the day if
you're really tired because
unfortunately that just makes it harder
to sleep at night again using the bed
only for sleep
and not doing other things in bed
avoiding sleeping in so sometimes the
things that feel
um
better for you when you have trouble
sleeping like sleeping in or taking a
nap they actually just make it harder to
sleep that night and it's so hard I
think a lot of us work jobs whether
you're working on the stripper where
we're also in the valley where maybe you
take a quick little five minute nap
because it's a long day or hours are
long it's got to be hard if you're
talking to a patient or whatever the
case would be to sort of get that out of
their routine yes
um and so there are kind of tips to
maximize that so if you do want to take
a nap try to keep it like 30 minutes or
less and as early in your day as
possible so you know morning or
afternoon or whatever that equates to
for shift workers
um and yeah I mean it is challenging you
have to be kind of motivated to be able
to want to do this because it's sort of
short-term pain for long-term gain right
you have to get through some of that
initial tiredness and fatigue and then
you'll you will have better sleep but it
is it can be tough I'm just curious in
your experience I know you're relatively
new to the valley but just how big of an
issue is sleep deprivation
here elsewhere how much are we all
suffering with bad sleep a lot yeah yeah
sleep deprivation is a big like National
problem I think we're just generally not
getting enough sleep it probably I don't
know about research but anecdotally I
think it's certainly probably worse here
because we do know that shift workers
suffer because it's hard to stay on a
different schedule our bodies are kind
of wired for a normal schedule so I
think it is an issue here so what can
you do we've talked about you know
getting in the the Rhythm of Life right
when when do you need medication when do
you need to seek other sorts of
treatment that go beyond not taking a
nap or staying in a routine right so if
you've tried kind of the basic sleep
hygiene tips like using the bed only for
sleep trying to stay at the same time
wake up at the same time every day
you're still having these problems and
it's causing you to stress during the
day right like you're feeling fatigued
cranky irritable it's been lasting for
three months or so that's when you could
seek some help either from a physician
or actually even a psychologist we have
CBT for insomnia cognitive behavioral
therapy friends insomnia that helps you
kind of formally use these techniques in
a way to help your sleep it's there's a
lot to it and obviously it's it's more
than you know having the right kind of
pajamas or the right kind of pillow or
the certain kind of comforter it's it
goes deeper than that but it's important
to address it because it has so many
other effects on our lives
yeah I mean if you don't sleep well you
have so many issues you're not feeling
your best emotionally it's hard to kind
of problem solve in our normal ways you
get more easily stressed out I mean I
think probably most people have
experienced that if you haven't had
enough sleep you're more cranky
um
it can cause like or can be associated
with like motor vehicle collisions so it
can have a lot of issues
um so definitely important to work on
well I'm glad we're here to talk about
it Dr Nicole short from UNLV sleep
psychology is an important aspect of it
we thank you for joining us appreciate
it